you fool
oh did I ever tell you this story about
Bill Cosby no so so I dated a girl in
like oh five OH six or seven in New York
beautiful girl mixed mixed race and like
cool whatever great and she used to talk
about she some Bill Cosby came up one
time she was like oh mr. Koz me what a
sweet man I was like what what what are
you doing buddy huh she's like oh yeah
one time I was on the street crying and
mr. Cosby walked up and introduced
himself it was like why are you crying
and and and and you know and we struck
up the friendship and I was like he was
trying to [ __ ] him just so you know I
was like just saying I was trying to
[ __ ] it she's like no he was not trying
to [ __ ] me like and and and like what
are you talking about like no I was
joking
again like I'm an animal for suggesting
it like oh you're so Boris why would you
possibly think right that's like cuz I
[ __ ] met the guy and he's not a good
dude and and so she she defended him to
me he used to take me to place just all
this [ __ ] I'm like okay he just had a
long game yeah man and so then all this
Cosby [ __ ] comes out then I text her I
go so what do you think what do you
think you're a boy and she goes uh she
said something like I think it like he
absolutely did it and I think his wife
was in on it which again I don't know
what that what she meant by that but so
then I weird text back affordance he
goes you know one time I was supposed to
meet him in Philadelphia and he told me
what to wear and how to wear my hair oh
geez and she goes and thankfully I got
sick she was gonna do it she was gonna
what she wanted yeah wow that was the
time yeah and set up yeah and he he was
going to take her to the ultimate
musical
and she and thankfully she got sick and
didn't go and and I was like and the
whole time what it's like yeah that's
the thing that one of the things with
some of these stories is like why would
Bill Cosby want to be friends with some
lady do you not even like what just
because you're great-looking yeah well I
think it's entirely possible that a guy
could be friends with a beautiful again
I don't even though he wants to [ __ ] her
just keep it together and just be
friends with her and you know find some
interesting muse I think it's impossible
but I do think it's not very likely in
my experience with humanities right no
and also why would a guy torture himself
like that why it's like when a guy has a
hot nanny dummy ugly nanny yeah [ __ ]
don't why do that to yourself the hot
nanny always winds up being a pro
[ __ ] everybody I know she's hot too
yeah does she know job time oh no she
says food sweats I'm sure we're spits
all day
let me pick that up for you talking
about you're such a good dad
yeah like just don't hire a hot nanny
yeah I would I would give that advice as
well I wouldn't hire a hot assistant
that's a good device as well I don't
know ever told you this story
so so my I hired an assistant for the
sexy for the second season Chapelle show
right and um and interviewed a bunch of
people and this girl came in super just
like sharp just like I could just tell
she was sharp and but she also happened
to be good-looking and so I hire and
Chappelle sees her and goes word she was
the most qualified and I was like yeah
she was the most qualified now I was
like yeah she was the most qualified
believe me now and I was proven right
because she has since gone on to produce
ghostbusters and the heat and all these
movies and she just happens to be good
luck but it was it was like I [ __ ]
knew it I [ __ ] told you she was
qualified she's just good she's what we
talk
about with that girl you'd met Cosman he
wasn't a nice guy I met Cosby at Arsenio
one time because I'm a million years old
I went to our I met a woman named joy
Dolce he used to be in the talent
Department and Arsenio and she was
friends with Dave cuz Davey's did
Arsenio whatever whatever so she would
like just go hey come by the show to
that this is like in when Arsenio was on
the original like in 94 so I went by one
day and Cosby was the guest and he liked
and he could just like kind of [ __ ]
berated me about like he was talking
about the history of slavery and he's
like and then the Dutch man came and he
pointed to me I was like I'm not Dutch
anybody just like didn't I go I was like
okay but it was just that he was just a
really condescending dude and I was 19
so you know he had a right to be
condescending but not really but I'll
whatever like I Bill Cosby is a
brilliant [ __ ] guy and but I just
he's just not
I wouldn't can i I mean know what I know
now he's a real piece of garbage but but
uh but the my interaction with him at
that time was not like wasn't Pleasant
right and just seeing how he talked to
people it's just like yeah this guy's
[ __ ] not a good dude